welcome everybody to the final episode
of the year here on the most potent
political talk show on in the world
today I would say many people would
think of the likes of who's a who's a
big political speaker ELA Bill Maher
Bill Maher well yeah he's on HBO though
but we're bigger than whoever you popped
into your head certainly by a big shot
and approved that to you we have with us
back again the great Andrew yang with
another incredible showing in the six
presidential debates it's an honor and a
privilege to have with us the great
fantastic yang gay yay rolling in on the
Gatsby my god here comes the next
president of the United States yeah
[Music]
wearing our official Andrew yang merge
which Ian Ian was at the rally yesterday
with the childish gambino and yourself
yeah he was in line for hours to get us
this merch the greatest merch I'm
grateful to him grateful to Donald
Glover for making the merch and for
helping us launch it in LA he's such a
great guy I don't know if you had a
chance to sit down with him no I haven't
but he's got street cred and real
recognize real as they say so that was
cool to see I think you all would get
along famously he's very very human you
know yeah you spend time with him he's
really very elevated in this thinking
hmm well I'd love to have the
opportunity but since I've got you here
let's talk about well you just came off
the the debate yeah and I have to say
that it was a fantastic debate
definitely the most interesting and I
think you know I've been watching a lot
of coverage and your name has finally
started
to come up a bit are you noticing that
as well yeah the team is thrilled about
it I've been named one of the winners
from the debate in a lot of mainstream
columns it's funny having you trying to
figure out who's like the apex of
political talk shows yeah do you have an
answer to that you know some of the
names that would have jumped out to me
would have been George Stephanopoulos
Jake Tapper people like that our
competitors I'm just grateful to you for
having me on because I know you know
politics isn't necessarily the focus
because people have other more fun
better things to talk about
yeah it's hard to get into a lot of
people it's oversaturated that's why I
think you are such a great kind of date
because you make it interesting and not
just so political it's actually
interesting for anyone I feel like oh
thank you that's certainly a goal and
I'm not a politician
I actually have something of a low
interest in politics although you did
study poli-sci is that right yeah so I
mean I can talk about my development so
I was a debater in high school I went to
the world public speaking and debating
championships of 1992 in in London where
I got destroyed by anyone with a British
accent and so I studied political
science and economics in college and
then I went to law school spent five
very unhappy months as a lawyer hmm but
there became a point when I followed
politics I actually had a list of goals
and one of my goals was to like elevate
politician but I didn't want to be one
hmm and I thought I saw what happened I
thought like wow what a what a drag most
of these political jobs are especially
now in this climate
so my running for president I joke that
my wife Evelyn would have run the other
direction if she'd known right so now
she's on the campaign trail and
enjoying the warmth and love of the
support we get ya the yang gang is
strong and vocal and it's been great to
your I mean the last time we had you on
was wha
G how long ago was that six seven months
ago or something I mean back then you
were coming up but I feel like now it's
been a steady increase and even looking
back at the recent debate you still
talked the least amount yet you've stood
out in my opinion the most is your
strategy when I watch YouTube eight I
feel like in US you you don't waste
words is that part of your strategy up
there you speak very directly very
purposefully and you you're very
succinct I find oftentimes you're done
talking before you're a lot of time is
up and people are like kind of making a
statement and that and not what is that
right it's been a combination of things
certainly we've gotten incredible
reception from debates that I have not
spoken that much right we're even last
night the team was telling me I'm not
sure what the number is but I think
we've raised over half a million since
last night's debate immediately and it
has no real I think it's going to come
out that I've raised as much or more
than any other candidate after last
night really and I didn't talk as much
as many as half yeah yeah and and so one
my natural inclination is to answer a
question that's asked of me you do
actually answer the question I think
it's yeah one of the reasons why they
debates are such a tall Intolerable I
mean it's so it's always the same it's
like they disk and answers and then you
ask him a real question and they end up
veering off and back into their talking
points yeah you know I did not realize
how bad it was until I was in this mix
and even this context where I enjoy
sitting with people like you having
conversations apparently a lot of
politicians avoid these sorts of antics
like the plague which makes no sense to
me at all well it's fear I suppose of
gaffes I mean
you know Hillary Clinton was on Howard
Stern recently and it was just it was
such a breath of fresh air to hear her
speaking so candidly and casually with
him I truly think that if she would have
done that during the election she
probably would have won probably because
you know III saw people who were Trump
supporters saying saying that there was
a story that came out that during the
Hillary Clinton campaign there were
something like eight people that had to
approve any tweet oh my goodnes example
I'd like a tweet committee that's
incredible Trump doesn't have that like
his committee is like eight brain cells
getting together like is this a good
idea yeah so Hillary now probably feels
like she has nothing to lose and I can
become more casual which is a shame
because it's self-defeating you know
what well I can dig into this a little
more I think it's really important what
happened with Hillary Clinton's campaign
is that they knew they were gonna raise
a billion dollars they had all of this
staff at every level so you can have
eight people to approve the tweet like
the the tweet committee and so you have
all of these layers of people around you
that are then like okay Hillary talked
about this this this and nothing else
and don't talk about any of this list of
things tell you what the list of things
you can't talk about is so long it's
easier for you just to say these five or
six things and she's surrounded by
dozens hundreds of people who are
sending her this message and then she
does an interview and then she seems
like an automaton you're right yeah like
that that's what happens in these
campaigns it's one reason why I've
seemed different is that in the
beginning our team was you know three
four people we were starting out in my
mom's apartment so there's no committee
big like yang you definitely shouldn't
say this and then now as we've risen
even though our team is
bigger the same dynamic holds but I
understand why Hillary's incentives
pushed her in a particular direction I
think they just thought it was so safe
so assured they had only just to lose
from any potential risk as small as it
may be you know yeah
and and that's the the way you like in
it's like if you're a really big
corporation with a franchise you know a
franchise that's worth a billion dollars
then you have this massive set of
incentive to like circle the wagons
protected in in Hillary's case they were
like of course we're gonna win or we're
gonna lose the Trump yeah and they were
literally already picking the picking
out the chairs in DC being like hey
you're gonna be ambassador to
Switzerland and you're gonna be like
they literally had it all mapped out
yeah I mean she said on Howard Stern
that she didn't even have a losing
speech prepared you know there was only
one outcome for them but there you have
it I think the landscape is changing and
I really think when I look at that
debate stage everybody's just toeing the
line and I mean it's like I found myself
fast forwarding some of the other people
cuz it's like dude you already said that
five times in this single debate but let
me ask you what is it like for you to
stand on that stage with some of the
most prominent political figures of all
time I mean of our generation certainly
and to and to be sharing a stage with
them because did you expect already to
be have gotten as far as you have then
this is definitely one of the higher end
scenarios I had mapped out I had some
low end scenarios projected where you
start as like a lone man on a mission
and you end as a load bit out of it's
like they're driving the van around New
Hampshire hey guys and I could have
lived with that because you know you you
do what you think is right you fight for
what you believe in and sometimes you
win sometimes you lose like I could have
lived with that but seeing the yangyang
grow all of the past number of days and
weeks and then being on this debate
stage one of the fun things about run
for president is you wind up getting to
know the other candidates in personal
ways because you're in the green room
with them or you're in the union hall
with them or you're the fish fry with
them like whatever it is you're just
interacting with them as candidates and
people so you get used to it pretty
quickly like now I have I mean I'll tell
you some fun stories so I've been around
Bernie maybe half a dozen times and then
I wasn't sure if he'd like me because
you can't really tell with Bernie
mm-hmm he said to a journalist I like he
Andrew and I was so touched I was like
yeah interview I was like pretty like
that's pretty badass and and then the
next time I saw him at the next debate
in Atlanta I was like hey Bernie thank
you for saying something nice about him
to that journalist and then Bernie put
his arm around me and was like of course
I like you Andrew to the table just told
me was you know excited about me so that
dynamic joe and i actually bond very
naturally and a lot of things he's the
most natively concerned about the impact
of technology on the economy of the
folks at least i've interacted with
directly on this topic so i will say you
know like I've now become increasingly
friendly with more and more of the
candidates but there is a generational
gap between me and them so like I said
last night I miss camel I miss Corey
like I miss Beto and Tulsi like these
are people that I frankly feel more of
like a natural connection to because
they're around my age in the same
generation was there something that you
wish they'd asked you on the debate
stage but didn't to me the and we talked
about this last time I was here and I
touched on it
just a smidgen it was about trying to
align the measurements of our economy
with our people and that right now so
many of the answers to the questions
last night hinged on our current notion
of GDP and jobs and profitability
one of them said hey can we move towards
renewable energy if it's going to cost
fossil fuel jobs in the short term and
you look at that and say and it and I
considered trying to interject but I was
like it's gonna be a complicated idea to
get into the debate context that if you
were to incorporate the cost of climate
change into our economy it would be
trillions of dollars tens or hundreds of
thousands of American lives over time
and so you'd look up and say the most
expensive thing we can do is nothing
or continue down this path and so if you
were to integrate our economic
measurements with sustainability and
it's related our wellness and life
expectancy climate change is influencing
our health in various ways in very
negative ways so we have to try and
actually measure the 21st century
economy by our own well-being and if we
did that then you would see that
fighting climate change is actually
cheaper I do love how you connect
everything it's a very holistic I guess
approach with are you combine everything
with the well-being of people and I
think I I wish that more people talked
about that yeah the the thank you HeLa
and if you reflect on it for a moment
you think what should the purpose of our
economy be if it's not our well-being
and right now GDP is going to get higher
and higher as technology does more and
more and more and more of us are going
to be left behind and depressed and
anxious yeah and so if you don't get
those measurements right then you wind
up in this tug of war that I think many
of us are already feeling mm-hmm
I so appreciate and that's so truth like
one of the questions they posed was you
know the GDP is and the economy is doing
better than evident but the the real
point you know was well why doesn't like
what does that mean for real people
just cuz the stock the sp500 game
and 50 points yesterday that doesn't
affect 90% of people living in America
you know it doesn't and and that's the
disconnect mm-hmm where the top well the
the 80% of the stock market wealth is
held by the top eight percent of
Americans to your point right so in at
the bottom 50 percent of Americans own
essentially zero yeah so you're beating
people over the head saying stock
markets are stock markets are up and
then people are being like the stock
market even right now like for most
people especially if you're young
because if you're young I just saw this
table that came out that said that the
share of wealth for young people is much
much lower than it's been for Gen Xers
or certainly boomers and so if you're a
young person with this pile of student
loan debt and this tenuous job that
doesn't have any benefits and you're
barely treading water like what does S&P
500 mean to you and you know I think it
can only contribute to all these the
depression anxiety because all the time
you're hearing on the radio on the TV
that GDP is great the economy is great
it's booming and then meanwhile if you
if you compare that to how your own life
is going where you can't even live
recreationally yeah you're like dude
what am I doing wrong
that is the subtext of all of them and
and so if you were to actually just put
out the real measurements saying hey we
have a student loan debt load that's
unprecedented 1.6 trillion dollars
mental health is decreasing drug
addictions at record highs and you were
to put these measurements out then you
would see just how poorly many of our
people are doing and then you'd put
energy towards solving those problems
and then if you were doing poorly you'd
be like oh I knew it wasn't my
imagination because turns out a lot of
us are doing poorly right like it's very
hard to solve a problem if you can't
identify it and then establish
measurements that help you improve I
think part of the problem too was kind
of
my generation is I feel like the whole
generation is kind of stuck in a rut is
that you've dude this whole idea of
American determinism and self-made nests
is like you you blame yourself and and
also your parents and your elders blame
you too in a way
maybe there's no worse part they don't
explicitly say it right but you can tell
it's like it's somehow your fault like
it's like dude brah I did it I made it
what's up you you yeah living with me
you know
and back when you bought a house it was
freaking you know like $1,000 and you
could actually do a part-time job and
pay for college but because college was
30% the price of what it is now like I'm
a numbers guy we have set up the next
generation to fail by the numbers and
the worst part is then we blame them for
it but hey it's because you know your
your attitudes not right or like you
want everything and it's really a moral
it's super messed up I go around the
country and I say to young people I am
sorry for the disaster we have left you
and when you think about that message
generally you think okay climate change
but it's not just climate change it's a
dysfunctional government that can't
solve problems it's an economy that by
the numbers is stacked against you
survive that college is 250 percent more
expensive than it was when I went to
college did it get 250% better no and
then we've said the young person a must
be your fault somehow that we've like
jacked up these prices on you and then
you're gonna graduate and find a job
what's up yeah stop that's why they suck
it's like hey what we've done is we've
kicked all of the stable jobs away now
we're automating them away you know and
it's much easier to automate away
frankly an entry level like insurance
agent or job that college graduate might
have done in the past and now they have
the debt but they don't have the job to
come with it there's a forty to forty
four percent
underemployment rate for recent college
graduates right now so if you are lucky
enough to graduate with your debt load
there's almost a 50/50
are gonna do a job that didn't require a
college degree and you know where that
does not show up the headline
unemployment rate cuz they're like job
check barista looks good right
and then they yell at you and being like
unemployment side record low and it's
like what my job is my not the job that
I was supposed to to do out of college
right also I saw on patriot act which
saw you on there too he was just talking
about how the elderly are now also not
able to really retire in dignity because
they also don't have enough savings and
I just it's it's crazy because now it's
also catching out to the boomer
generation who are criticizing us you
know but they have yeah how are they not
able to retire like you guys boarded the
wealth we're screwed and now we have to
support their old asses what happens is
they hoarded the wealth but again
there's massive diversity within that
generation so by share of generational
wealth they have more of it than any
other generation but there are still
many many poor boomers who are going to
work until the day they die because they
don't have meaningful savings and that
curve gets aggressively worse over time
where like if you look at millennials
and project forward like no one's gonna
have any say my generation Gen X is like
somewhere in between but not great and I
see this all the time campaigning in
Iowa New Hampshire and Ohio and
everywhere else where senior citizens
hold your parents 17:70 yeah mine are 79
and 72 and there comes a point when your
parents start being very at least I'll
just speak for myself there came a time
when my parents became very very
cost-conscious and judicious a long time
yeah maybe they worried the whole time
but there was a point when talking to my
mom in particular like it started to
dawn on me that that their earning power
has essentially been determined you know
they have their kitty of savings and
they have passive income and Social
Security they can
and that's it that defines their
economic reality mm-hmm I've met
Americans around the country who had
that same same reality and as a young
person when I was a middle aged person
but certainly when I was a young person
like its kind of foreign cuz you're like
who the heck knows with a future holds
sky's the limit maybe I'll get a raise
tomorrow like you don't know but for
them it's like oh they know and because
of that they have this attitude of
resource scarcity because they know
exactly what's going to come in and so I
meant Americans around the country where
they know what's coming in and it's not
enough yeah where they have social
security and social security might be
something like a thousand eleven hundred
a month and that's all they have it's
not enough for anything yeah so the what
what Hasan said in a patriot act is
right we have a retiree crisis in this
country where senior citizens are going
to be working until the day they die and
that retiree crisis just compounds over
time it's it's right name yeah I mean
it's gonna be a total [ __ ] show for the
current Millennials are gets worse and
worse you know it's true I think of my
own parents they own a house that they
rent out and they get a couple thousand
dollars a month and that and that with
the Social Security and I still help
them but they said they have like a
fairly decent source of cash but when I
think of like how hard it is to even buy
a house now for our generation I mean
yeah I don't see that ending well and so
many people work on freelance and
there's no benefits and no yeah majority
of new jobs are tempting or contract
jobs all of the benchmarks that you used
to associate with a middle-class life of
becoming harder and harder to come by so
it used to be it's like of course home
ownership it's like hey the real estate
crazy expensive go to college hey let's
make college crazy expensive and people
are getting increasingly distraught
because the benchmarks are more and more
out of reach
and then we pretend like it's not all
good it's on them and better than it's
ever been and and the numbers are
showing up in something and people have
mixed mixed feelings about this but so
every life stage is getting pushed back
and so you're seeing things like
marriage decline you're seeing things
like having kids decline American child
births are at record lows right now and
so you can look up to at that and say
like well there are a host of reasons to
me that's tied in to the fact that you
don't feel like you have a stable
middle-class life getting married it's a
big financial decision to have a kid
yeah unfortunately unfortunately yeah
and so getting married is in many cases
an act of optimism and prosperity having
kids as an act of optimism and
prosperity and there's just less of it
to go around for young people in
particular where you know they're
trapped in their parents basement with
these debt loads and they feel like they
don't have the stability to be a partner
or much less of a parent right and on
top of it they feel like it's their
fault but let me here's an issue that
came up that you had a different
response than the other candidates on
the issue of impeachment which is kind
of what's dominating the news cycle
these days your answer was that that
that we may be focusing too much on
impeachment what did you mean by that
the crucial number right now is zero
because that's the number of Republicans
that have crossed party lines and said
hey impeachment is a good idea it
doesn't look good right
Oh to bring I mean and you you don't
need zero Republicans you need 20
Republicans to the Senate to switch
sides so if you look up and say okay you
need 20 you have zero yeah like so what
I said last night was this is like a
ball game but you're watching that you
recorded that you know the score is not
a fun ball game to watch and so there is
a lot of history being made in some ways
you can't fault journalists and
politicians for saying you know that we
need to focus all of our
intention on this but as a rational
person when you're like look you need 20
you have zero this is going to be a bust
Donald Trump two months from now is
gonna be crowing about total vindication
and total exoneration and Democratic
witch-hunt and the rest of it so if you
know that that's the way it's probably
going to play out then you need to start
building towards the election and you
need to start trying to solve the
problems I got Trump elected in the
first place and I don't think Democrats
really took to heart the message of
Donald Trump's victory we talked about
this last time when you thought it was
inconceivable you know many of us
thought it was inconceivable that Trump
would win and he did win based upon a
narrow margin of victory in a few states
but to me it's a giant red flag if tens
of millions of Americans say let's take
a bet on the narcissist reality TV star
because we have lost faith in our
government's ability to solve our
problems if you lose to that figure in
any way then you have to soul search and
say what the heck is going on with us
like how the heck do we lose to that guy
and unfortunately I think all the energy
around impeachment is falling back into
this narrative instead of saying like
well let's try to solve the problems
it's that Trump is the problem right so
I'm Pro impeachment I think what he did
was wrong I think that we do have a
constitution and voting to uphold it is
a positive thing but I'm also a realist
if you need 20 you have zero then let's
just freaking try and wrap this game up
and get on to the next game where you
actually can win and that's the ballot
box in 2020 that's we're gonna win and
it's right around the corner you know
it's we can the people can vote then but
if you're in California you can vote
starting think it's February 3rd oh wow
there's because you you legit vote I
think it's March 3rd but then you can
early vote like a month before and I
think you can vote by mail in California
hmm and I will say if you're in
California this is all very odd
territory because traditionally
Californians have had essentially zero
input on who becomes president as it's
already foretold by then
yeah because California was relatively
late in the nomination process and so
here's the fun part you get number one
Iowa to New Hampshire three Nevada for
South Carolina and then California was
like like 21 or something like it didn't
matter but this time California got
moved up to five how excited yeah yeah
because California was sick of not being
in the game so they said we're gonna
move up to five and this thing's not
gonna be settled by the time it gets to
California so this is all very new for
Californians that's very cool actually
that's exciting
by the way last time I was not a citizen
and now I am you made America but a
great day for the country well she she
entered much like you did on the gas
celebration America should have been
celebrating actually you know a OC
tweeted ela congratulations
yes how cool is that big honor I think
it's the greatest place to a value the
opportunity to live here very much
that's beautiful hmm hit me with that
American music Chris a has an have you
settled the beef thank you okay thank
you we're dumped that yeah have you
settled the beef with MSNBC to my count
they've left you out of a graph 15 times
is that right or is it more than 15 I
think that's about the last count I saw
and I feel like you didn't want it you
didn't want to go there with them but at
a certain point you got a address an
issue that does affecting your campaign
i me it's out rate it's what it what
that went on there you know it is very
very baffling to us all and we're in
talks with them to try and put it behind
us because it doesn't do anyone any good
for them to be
treating us differently than other
candidates and frankly for me not being
on there talking to voters because a lot
of yeah yeah Dems get their info from
MSNBC but I gotta say it's been a
massive like source of confusion and
concern what it's so weird that it's
every time it's like your face just
isn't there and then after the debate
they're interviewing Korey bookie who
Booker who I'm a fan of but he wasn't
even in debate where you want him an
MSNBC at all last night no I wasn't I
mean what the hell is that where did
they invite you I do not know I have to
ask my team you're on CNN I saw you
there yeah you know my team handles the
press engagements okay I'm not sure if
they asked okay let's talk about policy
China I'm worried I found myself
concerned about China
I find myself concerned about their way
that they treat theirs their sidon
citizenry with the with the social
rating system with the facial
recognition you know they say that the
Chinese citizens now have social scores
you can lose points
by participating in activism or protests
and what could happen when you get a low
social score you can not leave the
country you can not use public
transportation stuff like this and so
the way that they are finding to control
their citizenry is some very frightening
things from the future of civilization
as I see it a threat to that I also
wonder about if the United States should
be more active in supporting Hong Kong
protesters that seems to me a great
opportunity for for America to prop up
and an ally and a Democratic Society
over there in that part of in China and
so I wonder if you were to become
president what would be your approach to
these issues in China and what are your
thoughts on that the most reprehensible
thing going on
China right now is the concentration
camps for like the Weger ethnic minority
yeah it is awful I don't know if you've
seen some of this I have I should have
brought that up yeah I know it's
freaking like straight out of the stone
Age's type stuff it's beyond it's well
well they round up a bunch of their
Muslims right yes and they're doing
cultural re-education because they want
a homogeneous society and religion is
frowned upon and communist society
correct me if I'm wrong anywhere yeah
it's even darker than that in some cases
they send the weaker men to like a work
camp or concentration camp and then they
send soldiers to to hang out with their
wives and their absence I mean like
really really dark [ __ ] hmm that you
seen you're like this is inhuman and in
an effort to to what resettle the family
or what yeah just to try and essentially
excise their country of this minority
they want to work the men to death and
remarry the women is that the idea
yeah they or they want them to
essentially break up the family unit so
that the next generation is not brought
up in the same religion the same way
right so but everything else you've
named also but they're Hong Kong is
tricky because Hong Kong was a British
colony long time and then the Brits
handed it back to China and then now
it's in this hand over a period where
it's considered a semi-autonomous zone
but if you look up and say okay what
country is hong kong part of you would
have to conclude china because it was a
british colony that it was returned to
the chinese a number of years ago and so
the question is how can we support the
people in hong kong to keep the abuses
from scaling up there and in some ways
the chinese haven't done what you would
fear which is go in and do a military
oppression
Hanneman style but there's plenty of
dark stuff happening happening in hong
kong and I said last night
they banned face masks there so they
could use
facial recognition technology to
identify protesters and then round them
up afterwards the biggest thing we can
do to bring pressure on the Chinese is
to make it clear to them that if they
abuse human rights they're going to be
consequences and those consequences have
to be economic really because that's the
main language the Chinese understand
they have two primary overriding
priorities at all times
number one maintain robust economic
growth and the number two preserve
social order so the question is can you
make number one powerful enough so that
they curb the abuses and number two the
social credit system is part of as part
of that set up and do you also watch
black mirror and you see those episodes
yeah so reminds you of that black mayor
episode in Tim to me that is hand in
hand with their total lack of privacy
rights the fact that any interaction you
have in any context gets recorded they
have a real powerful surveillance state
there and they're ramping up their
technology to make it unprecedented in
human history right so to me here's the
approach number one you say look you
benefit from our trade relationship from
your global commerce if you go past a
certain point in terms of your human
rights abuses you're going to pay a real
price number two on the technology side
they're actually trying very hard to
build up a parallel tech ecosystem which
is really disastrous potentially for
everyone over time they used Google Apps
until very recently and now they've
transitioned to their own homegrown
operating system does that mean that the
government Outlawz prohibits Google
based devices well they're not using
them now and it's an open question
whether the Chinese government
prohibited them or the US government
said hey Google you're not allowed to
work with the Chinese on these
but a lot of the Google Apps we all know
are essentially open source
where or if not open source they make
the license freely available so if you
were the Chinese and you had to come up
with your own set of apps and operating
system it would really suck
especially because Google had it all
figured out for you so they were using
Google and now they developed their own
homegrown operating system and apps that
they're exporting to other countries
that they're trying so the risk is that
if for whatever reason consumers start
using that and we become for whatever
reason reliant are you worried about
data privacy breaches yes yeah so you
can imagine a world where because we
know that Chinese technology firms and
the Chinese government have a very close
relationship and so if you succeed in
exporting that technology platform to
the rest of the world then you
essentially have the Chinese
government's eyes and hooks in
everything so that's what you have to
try and prevent and the way to prevent
it is to set up a world data
organization that's analogous to the
World Trade Organization and say here
the standards and protocols for data and
Technology get the EU and Japan to buy
in and then make it so that if you are
an unaffiliated country that it's
obvious that you have to go with the
world tech standards and not the Chinese
text standard and then if you were China
and you look up and say wait a minute I
can't export my stuff effectively
because it doesn't follow these
protocols our stuff doesn't work with
anyone else's stuff at the extreme end
they would say maybe it's better for us
if we join the world on this one because
then at least our stuff will be
interoperable and also right now I'm
gonna bet their software is terrible
compared to Google's and everyone else's
like if you're a third world country and
they're generally developing countries
and China comes and says hey use our
tech you're like I do not want to use
your technical all your tech is terrible
it's free you know oh but you know ours
is virtually free - but but like if
you're at the Congo and China's
okay we're like building all of your
stuff we're building you a coal power
plant use a software that congos like I
guess we have so that's the game they're
playing and we have to make it so that
that game loses that game losing
actually is the best way we can protect
human rights because then if you're
trying and you look up and say well I
need to join this world organization
then you say well if you want to join
this world organization you need to have
some kind of privacy rules in check you
need to not be abusing your own people
in these ways is there any efforts to
put an organisation like that together
I'm happy to say that we're starting to
take some steps we have some proposals
out certainly if I'm president we can
get this done relatively quickly because
the EU and Japan would like yeah all
right and this is the brainchild of a
guy named Ian Bremmer who's this
brilliant thinker on global security
matters and so Ian running with this
ball right now hmm
that's great you know and and that kind
of leads into another issue with China
that that scares me frankly is that the
race for AI supremacy you know I feel
like China has such a strong central
government
I mean authoritarian really that they
are able to make these big swinging
decisions like for example just to
invest they decide to invest all this
money and AI technology and here and
other developed countries were lagging
behind and you look at we had a nuclear
race and it could very well be that the
the next would be the next workers right
I mean the next new world will be
established by a I want you to once you
break through on that and it can start
solving its own problems you you all of
a sudden are you go light years instead
of years ahead right yeah and so you're
right to be concerned so is that
something that leaders are currently
working towards Eve
evening the playing field there people
thinking about this issue there are
people thinking about it but they're not
in our government I mean so we at this
point have an innovation model that's
very much driven by the leading
technology companies mm-hmm no if you
rewind several generations you had all
of these government scientists and lab
coats like buried on their Mountain in
New Mexico or wherever coming up with
things and then now all of those
scientists work for SpaceX Amazon Google
Facebook Microsoft to some extent so
they are deeply concerned that China is
going to leapfrog us in AI I'm deeply
concerned there was a joke that people
in AI used to tell it was how far behind
is China and AI from the US and the
answer was 12 hours because they would
wake up and then see what we did
now that joke doesn't really work
because is it that available they can
just see what we did the private
companies they don't make their stuff
publicly available right but there there
were some labs and universities that
would publish new stuff and then they
were so China was just like oh great
well so so here's the the broader
context the West is better on research
and breakthroughs than China we came up
with this machine learning AI
development tool that now
China has and machine learning gets
stronger and smarter based upon how much
data you feed to it like date is like
food of the algorithms so China now has
a massive lead in the level of data and
China also has a massive lead in the
level of computing infrastructure that
they make available to their firms so in
China AI is a national obsession more
Chinese watched AI beat the best human
go player the Chinese game of go right
then watch the Super Bowl in the US Wow
so so it a eyes
massive national and cultural priority
it's just an effort from the government
to to get interests in this thing that
they see is vitally important to their
future success
yes that's very interesting it's almost
like a propaganda machine in this case
right it's smart yeah I wish we did the
same thing so they have more data and
then the government says look we're
gonna spend billions even tens of
billions of dollars on computing
infrastructure as far as the eye can see
like Islands covered with server farms
like straight out of the matrix and I've
sat with the leading technologist in
Silicon Valley who looked at me and said
look we'll spend 1 billion two billion
dollars on computing infrastructure but
we can't spend ten billion hmm and
that's what the Chinese are doing and
the Chinese are saying hey go ahead and
use it
AI companies not REI can like Chinese AI
companies right use this ten billion
dollar infrastructure you have more data
now you have more computing power so our
AI will be smarter faster and they are
generally correct I asked a group of
Iowans last week I said okay so right
now they have more access to more data
than we do and they have more computing
infrastructure the only way for the u.s.
to win this would be if we have another
breakthrough past machine learning how
many of you think that that the u.s. is
going to take the lead base in another
breakthrough and like no hands went up
and I said how many of you think that
the Chinese will take a lead based upon
more data add more computing
infrastructures but we had wet on and I
looked at them and I said I agree with
you like if you have more data and more
computing infrastructure you're probably
gonna win this thing so what we have to
do is we have to go to our technology
firms and as president it'll be my my
pleasure to do this I'll say look we get
it we will match the Chinese
multi-billion dollar computing
infrastructure take it off your balance
sheets to maintain global leadership in
this field and in return then we'll ask
them for a few things - this actually
will ask them to allow us to have
someone that keeps them from destroying
humanity or do
doing something so i sat with with the
technologist you said to me flat-out he
said look our incentives right now on AI
are just to go as fast as possible
because we're competing with the other
tech firms we're competing with the
Chinese and if all of our incentives
were to go as fast as possible at one
point one of us is gonna do something
really problematic / disastrous do you
have a and he said he said like please
we could use some guidelines on this
because if you put guidelines on us and
the other firms were competing against
then we'd be less likely to break
something right worried about the other
guys you know probably what is one of
these scenarios for example where
someone who's moving too fast in the
development of AI does something that
becomes harmful disastrous to our
society what's an example of that so you
could have AI that I mean I don't want
to scare people but go ahead
let's get scared so uh let's say so I'll
just say something like you could have
weaponized AI that can hack just about
any public infrastructure that you can't
encrypt and protect because the AI is
sophisticated enough where it can break
through and then you could imagine if
that AI gets into the wrong person's
hands or wrong organizations hands then
it could be essentially like holding our
infrastructure hostage or maybe not even
holding every structure house may just
set it loose and then we wind up with
the lights off or quite some time I mean
there are scenarios like that there are
other darker scenarios or around and
these are the more the science-fiction
level where like the AI gets its own
agenda mm-hmm but there are realistic
scenarios where AI does something is not
intended to do in ways that hold that
does very large-scale damage I'm
thinking I'm now I want to think
practically about what this means so
China is on we're in a I race arms race
what's the endgame is it hacking as a
digital warfare I mean what is it that
will give them the edge practically
speaking so if you were to win in AI
economy-wide that would mean that you
could accomplish efficiencies of scale
that other economies would not and that
your firms would be smarter your
software would be more effective
everything would just start working
better and then it's very hard to
compete with that if you are another
country let's imagine for example that
you had AI that had figured out mobility
to the point where you could have
autonomous trucks and cars everywhere
and then there was one country that had
that software and it was actually safe
the level of savings for an economy of
having autonomous vehicles would be
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
and so if you had access to that
software and then say hey this will save
your economy hundreds of billions I'll
license it to you for 20 billion 30
billion or whatever it is then other
countries would start doing that and
then that would be their the new it's
the new oil as you say yeah data is a
new oil yeah and so if you had the AI
and you could harness the data
effectively then you win at an almost
unprecedented scale mm-hmm I mean it
sounds important that's real money know
that that's why the Chinese are fat like
essentially obsessed with this I mean
they're looking for ways that they can
become the new world player yeah and I
think they see that as almost like a
cheat code to piggyback to the front of
the line it's like how many like a Hail
Mary I'm sure you all do like sure you
do Ethan maybe not you know like you
played video games where you're like try
to upgrade your horse I played many
games so a eyes like that where it's
like oh man I'm starting to fall behind
it's like oh if I get this new unit type
upgrade that right I know exactly yeah
ai is is like that for the Chinese I
mean it seems concerning that that is
not even a topic on the debate or that
well no one really talks about it time
for this guy I agree with you the fact
is our government is 25 years behind the
technology our media come in 20 and all
the politicians are 25 years too old if
I'm being honest I mean I I don't want
to sound ages but I also don't mind if I
sound ages either because I think
politicians are getting they're too old
you know what I mean I once I want
someone there's too much going on in the
world I mean Joe Biden probably has a at
aol.com email yeah maybe I'll be likely
Jose Jose 77 I want to say so he's like
our parents right and that's terrified
so if your parents have you understand
their let it their technological
literacy that's not who you want up
against the Chinese AI machine yeah it's
not just the folks who are on the stage
I think with someone looked up the
average age of a congress person or
legislature in DC and I think it was 60
so why is that what's going on young
people not getting in the game or people
not electing young people I know that
there's kind of a second wave now but I
just think that our government body
wasn't meant to be run by by the olds by
old people who don't really understand
and more now more than ever maybe a
hundred years ago this the technological
aspect was abhorrent and the landscape
wasn't moving as fast and wisdom and old
age and you know good there is a
technical term for this as the
gerontology hmm like the rule by old
people
mm-hm and the u.s. is I believe
technically a gerund talker see Wow
how about that it's not great I mean you
know again and it's tough because you
know we like old people I love the old I
feel like that's like a slur no but the
rate of change is just accelerating is
getting faster all the time yeah so if
you could afford to be 10 20 years
behind like a number of decades ago you
can't afford to be 20 years right now
because what the heck happened the last
20 years you know the world has changed
mm-hmm and right now the government in
the u.s. unfortunately is like like the
flopping appendage behind like the rest
of you know it is like the tail like the
animals moving forward and the tails
like hey me too me too
and that's not gonna work ideally for us
in terms of some of the biggest problems
like AI like climate change like some of
the folks the the problems that you
genuinely need a federal government that
has its act together and that that's
where we are right now as a country
that's why I'm running for president
because I looked up and said okay here
are the big problems you can't solve
them unless the government gets its [ __ ]
together the government will not get it
[ __ ] together and then we all right so
what's the plan somebody's gotta do some
and so then I said well if I run for
president and bring enough Americans
together fast enough then we can get
into DC rewrite the operating system try
and modernize and upgrade it just be all
about solutions data-oriented modernize
it someone told me a story there's like
an Asian kid he went to work in DC and
when these congressional offices and
then they gave him some like work to do
about like opening mail or like entering
like something into a form so then he
being a smart kid he like wrote a script
where they did like did itself
and then they yelled at him for it he's
like I just made it so did the
government for that's insane a few
months and he was like it was terrible
and this was in a in a Congress person's
office DC is embarrassing that's how
rages I mean that it's funny but it's
also terrifying yeah you know yeah yeah
so if I get in there and can try and
make it like what I was saying that kid
is I was like look man we have to like
essentially have
a kid like you in every office we need
to look for you yeah we need to embrace
you I'll get you in there and being like
hey he's just gonna try and make stuff
work a little better and faster and you
know just see how it goes and like and
then just try and push the culture
forward you can't change it overnight
but I think you can get a lot done
faster than people think because they're
so far behind like you almost can't help
but do good in that situation it's what
do you would erase the what do you need
to get into the next debate in January
it's 5% now from percent yeah so we're
gonna get you one more percent before
the 10th is that right of January we're
gonna get that with one percent after
the last night yeah we already have one
of the polls we need we need you dealer
yeah so we we got a five percent
nationwide I think it was is that the
first one yeah so we need three more in
the early states or that's gotta feel
crazy it is it's like it's like one of
the games that we like all right what I
need now I do more polls the best way
that people can help in that direction
really is just make a donation between
now and December 31st at yank 2020 calm
because we'll take any donations and
then we'll put the money to work getting
our poll numbers up in the early States
that's where the money's going have you
seen any data following last night's
debate about are you polling better I
mean does it work those debates well we
we've gotten incredible response yeah
there are last night's debate I think
we've raised half a million cents the
debate already maybe more is that what
it is that it you just we want the money
so we can run the ads or if you know
people in Iowa and New Hampshire South
Carolina call them up be like hey it's
been a little while but have you heard
of Andrew yeah I got anything that
boosts our awareness in those states is
super helpful money is helpful spreading
the message via social media and other
ways is helpful but it's game time it's
crunch time and we have to save humanity
and we have approximately two months to
do it in so it is a great time though
because frankly you know we're right at
this crucial period where we can change
the course of this country and it's a
privilege to be here like the yang gang
has gotten us right to this point where
you can see the path it's a victory
there's no oil yeah it is
yeah and I I just reviewed some polling
numbers earlier today and the polling
for this campaign just shooting up in
terms of favorables both named awareness
and favorability have been skyrocketing
lately and even now my favorability is
actually higher than that of just about
any other politician I managed to throw
in a little little jokes little way out
to the crowd yeah yeah LMU
yeah I think it's awesome yeah we're
just on the cusp of breaking through it
feels great and thank you both for being
some of the oh geez and this it's my
pleasure
part of the yanking my brother is that
Genesis from my brother as as I told you
like him and yeah I tried to get here to
see you but he couldn't make it down
he's a teacher in Las Vegas
that's incredible have I met him because
I know yeah I don't know if you've met
him yeah check out the tape but I I
agree I think I've always felt that if
people could just hear your message and
see you then people are gonna start to
see that that you're different and
you're what we need right so I thought
last night's debate was a fantastic when
it's incredible to see you up on that
stage only seven people now it was such
a circus before with 12 what 15 how many
people were on the stage at one point
you know there was a 12 person debate 12
people I mean it's out so and there were
the debate where they had 20 and they
split it at two nights at 10 right yeah
so there's seven people there you're one
of them I mean my goodness
anyway we gotta get you those poles I
know we're low on time but I've got some
more things here and I just don't want
to stop so me neither let's go Mexican
cartels is another thing that that that
concerns me I mean is this a national
security issue for for America we have
what seems to be more and more a lawless
country on our southern border my
parents lived in Mexico for five years
and they were forced to leave as the the
violence moved into their small town in
the state of Alaska
there was a grenade fire I mean they
were there was a long game yeah and so
and you know there was this recent thing
with the the Mormons who were murdered
there terrible and they're not just
criminals they're they're so violent and
they're so ruthless what do what can we
do about this as an I mean it's a
continental issue I find why is Mexico
and America not collaborating on this is
it a fraction what's going on here what
do we do about this do you see it as a
issue oh yeah of course it's a major
issue on several levels it's one of
those situations where helping others
helps us yes no like we have to do
everything we can to help stabilize
what's happening in Mexico the tough
part is that there's a lot of corruption
there so you get there and you're like
hey let's break the backs of the cartels
and let's do something positive and the
cartels are bought and sold a lot of the
officials there that you'd hope to be
working with and the ones that aren't
are murdered yeah it seems like yeah so
it's a tough context to get positive
things done in but it's it's a situation
where if you do put economic aid and
resources to work it actually goes a
very very long way and one of the
reasons why people are trying to migrate
into the u.s. is because their towns are
being overrun right by violence it's not
I think these immigrants have been so
demonized it's how it's just it's
you know it's just such a shame I mean
they're they're escaping violence
they're not I don't know what people
think that about these like I remember
when Trump was uh during the election
there was this whole thing about them
the caravan right
yeah the caravan I mean he always has
these cheap political stunts one
approach we could take that would change
the resources available to the cartels
explore the legalization of certain
drugs yes and I'm open to looking at
legalizing different drugs that are not
just feeling the cartel but also in some
cases would frankly be an upgrade over
the opiates that many Americans are
currently getting addicted to what are
we talking about for arowana
marijuana is the easy I mean that's
already there yeah and this is not a
huge economic driver the cartels but
psilocybin mushrooms and psychedelics
yes I've been proven to what are they
selling is it heroin is it meth
marijuana yeah it's and so this is the
most dramatic one is I'm actually
looking to decriminalize opiates for
personal use because we have eight
Americans dying of drug overdoses every
hour in this country we've essentially
initiated this massive opiate addiction
plague and it was a disease of
capitalism
it started out Purdue Pharma prescribing
oxycontin right and saying it's a
non-addictive wonder drug and then there
was one point in our history not that
long or like you know 6-7 years ago
there were more opiate prescriptions in
the state of Ohio than there were human
beings in the state of Ohio I saw
60-member yeah that blew my mind and
they have these pain clinics on every
yeah corner with these crooked doctors
just writing scripts for people it was
unbelievable yeah so what happened was
oxycontin addiction morphed into
fentanyl and heroin and then a lot of
that is what's getting trafficked now
we've we've created this nation of
addicts and they've actually found that
oxycontin is now harder to get ahold of
than the illegal stuff right so you have
this massive drug trade and then it's
driving the resources so what I'm
proposing is we legalize opiates for
personal use which means if we catch you
with the drugs you
get the drugs taken away from you but we
don't send you to jail we send you to
treatment and counseling and then we set
up safe injection sites and save consult
consumption sites in the u.s. that are
controversial but they've been proven to
work and save lives and then if you did
this you could bring in some of this
drug use out of the shadows and then get
your user base down and then get the
economic resources that go into the
cartels down it's a dramatic move but I
was pushed in this direction by a high
school senior in Iowa believe was a town
called storm Lake and he said he's a
high school senior and his classmates
have fentanyl patches on their arms
addicted and I was like and then he said
like what can you do to help my
classmates and so I talked to him at the
event I was like what can we do and he
said well I'll tell you one thing like
they're not gonna let anyone know
they've got a problem because fentanyl
is illegal and they don't want to like
get a criminal record yeah there's yeah
for what yeah so so then I said oh my
gosh like how can you get that freakin
kids classmates help and they're you
know they're never gonna go to the cops
if like they're gonna freakin get busted
for it so then it's like well if you
actually decriminalize it so if they
went and said hey like help me get off
this stuff then you'd be like all right
like and then you don't get a criminal
record then you can actually start
making progress
so who sells them the opiates if we want
to cut out the cartel and Yordy your
league well decriminalize he
criminalizing it so where do they why
are they buying the drugs so right now
they're drawing it from they're buying
it from dealers yeah and then in my new
world that they'd still be blanket from
from dealers the dealers still go to
jail it's just the individual users
don't get sent to jail with the dealer
hmm so I'm not saying legalize it in
their way of like make it make it like
heroin available and I guess the cartel
is still essentially making the money
from supplying the dealers yeah so I'm
wondering I mean ultimately your vision
is that people start using it less yeah
like you have to try and attack them and
actually ask yeah you you have to try to
and when other countries have
decriminalized opiates in this
they saw reductions not just in overdose
rates but in abuse rates and then try
and and obviously we prefer a country
where fewer of us are addicted to drugs
yeah and this this addiction plague is
so rampant it's heartbreaking I'm in
Iowa and New Hampshire and people will
come to me and say my brother died my
son died like everyone has a story about
someone who died that's close to them
and it's disgusting like the fact that
we let this happen in in our country
because essentially of capitalism run
amok like Purdue Pharma made made thirty
billion dollars on this and then paid a
six hundred thirty five million dollar
fine they paid a two percent fine okay
oh yeah it's a good deal and like their
their family is now one of the richest
families in the country the Sackler
family so this is a disease where the
government essentially turned a blind
eye and let a drug company kill tens of
thousands of Americans for profit and
now we're left with the mess and it
actually is in the oil and the bill and
it's a it's a human toll you know it's
like you can't bring that person's son
back you can't bring that person's
brother back and it's fueling what's
happening with the drug cartels because
this is the majority of their business
mmm
because it morphed from oxy to heroin
and fentanyl and a bunch of the other
early which makes total sense you can
tell that you know it's the same thing I
don't know if people know that it's the
same thing it's just that these drug
companies have a pretty little packaging
and it comes from a doctor but it's the
same [ __ ] as that you get down to Mexico
shoot up in your arm pretty much you
know we're over medicating our people to
a very high level here in this country
and for some people if the drug is
what's going to help you then by all
means but it should not be the first
move or the first resort because the
fact is a lot of the drug interactions
and I've talked to many Americans who've
had this experience I think the doctor
doesn't really know how the drugs gonna
interact with you it's like you know
that I have you in the officer to be
like take this it's work for some of my
patients and then you stub your toe
here's oxycontin oh yeah like you were
like why are you giving me like why you
give me this painkiller it's like I'm
gonna be alright the bill I just take
its take it right what is going on right
yeah if anything we should be like
really need this like you have should
have to beg me for this thing because
the the fact is after they prescribed
oxy there was like I forget what the
percentage but there was like a you know
like let's call it like non-trivial is
like maybe like a 3% chance you're dead
within no it was true it was good doctor
there was like a there was like a you
know a 2 or 3 percent chance you were
dead within five years or ethic yeah
it's it's incredible like you go in for
something non-lethal and they prescribe
you something lethal and like a
non-trivial number
Wow well in the in the that that's
shocking and the essence of time I want
to ask you something I've never heard
you talk about what is your religious
faith and you believe that faith is
required to be President I was brought
up in an entirely secular household I
know my parents immigrated here and then
met his graduate students and I can't
remember them ever talking about their
own faith as a kid I had many Christian
relatives and so we spent some holidays
in church services and then I met my
wife Evelyn and she's Christian so we're
bringing our boys up in the church so
and we now go to church as a family
every weekend I'm home which
unfortunately now is not that many
weekends for me I always had this native
belief in a higher power or God or that
there was something driving us I always
had this deep sense of right and wrong
and I think that sense of right and
wrong was actually driven by a lot of
the comic books and science fiction
novels and whatnot I read as a kid where
like you know they're like good guys and
trying to do something positive so what
people ask my Bible in other words yeah
the church that we belong to is very
progressive they got a rainbow flag up
up front certainly I'm very excited to
have my little boys in that kind of
environment because like I can see that
they love it oh yeah I mean your guys
only
months but I mean you guys well we're
sector it's definitely a question
because I my parents were pretty
Orthodox but I'm not so now I wonder
like how do you like do you still do the
holidays yeah yeah yeah but what do you
do you think that faith is required to
be president because to at least what's
publicly known that there's never been a
secular or atheistic or agnostic
president they've all and it seems that
is candidates are touting their pious
Ness these days as a requirement I
certainly don't think it should be a
requirement I mean if you look up
millions of Americans self-identify as
non-religious or atheist and I have
friends who are some of the best human
beings I know who don't observe a
particular faith or religion some of
them have even gone so far as to set up
like their own type of community of like
humanist beliefs where you know you can
have very very deep values and love and
not be part of a religious faith or
community so I don't think it should be
a requirement at all if anything I think
we're somehow stigmatizing people who
weren't brought up in a religion as
somehow being less moral than others but
you know I don't believe that for a
second like again some of my best
friends that I admire the most are
people that don't participate in any
religious community
the freedom divid I'm sure that would be
a great thing and you know in the press
comments atheism agnostic non-religious
people is actually the goro as the
process growing group of well if you
want to say religious category of people
right so I do think that non-religious
people don't don't feel represented in
this country in many ways so I think
it's important I agree with that
completely
yeah and as president I will be very
proud to represent non-religious
Americans god bless in a in a non ironic
or I guess ironic way I'm gonna go fast
the freedom dividend you're giving
people $1,000 a month how does this play
into what a lot of your fellow
candidates are talking about with
universal health care for a university
by giving people $1,000 a month is the
idea to empower them to make those
financial decisions or do you also
believe that health care and university
should be free in addition to the
thousand dollars a month health care
should not be breaking our backs in a
way it is my goal is not to give you a
thousand bucks a month so you can give
it to the drug companies or why not like
well yeah we have to get our health care
cost under control and the best way to
do that is to make a plan available
that's very inexpensive a health care
should be a human right not means for
these giant companies to make tons of
money off of us that's different than
universities and education because
everyone needs health care frankly only
33 percent of Americans graduate from
college and that number is relatively
stable and so if you decide to make
College free you're subsidizing
something that's going to be enjoyed by
the top third of your people and just
because you've made that education free
doesn't mean that a higher percentage of
college graduates are going to be
employed in the kind of jobs that they
want to be I mean I like the
unemployment rate is 40 to 44 percent
right now and that doesn't miraculously
change if I bring the cost down so we're
better off putting money into people's
hands so that they go to college is
partially paid for they go to trade
school it's probably almost entirely
paid for if they decide to start a
business they would need to take care of
a loved one we need to treat different
paths equally this is something I'm a
little bit troubled by the democratic
recipe is that the Democratic recipe
assumes that everyone's gonna go to
college and that college will solve all
the problems neither of those things
seems to be true but by the numbers
again the percentage of Americans
graduating college has been essentially
stable over the last number of years and
unfortunately the rate of Americans who
attend college and don't finish has been
rising they
you have a 41% chance of not finishing
college within six years if you start
now and that's that's really high
you know like that what that suggests is
that we're putting people into college
that it's not a fit for they don't want
to be there they don't want to be there
and I mean right now sometimes they're
just like oh it's too much money or you
know I have other responsibilities so we
need to have a more personal a
personalized solution that doesn't say
college college college everybody so if
we're not paying for everybody's
university do you think that there's
something some sort of regulation to do
about the cost oh yeah
so that said we need to get the cost of
college under control and what I'm
proposing is that I looked at the
numbers colleges got two and a half
times more expensive not because of
professors not even because of
facilities it's because of
administrators the percentage of
administrators to students has gone up a
hundred fifty Brian I think I know why I
think everyone watching this knows why
but if you're a university you're
becoming more and more bureaucratic and
complex and to send up hiring more and
more non-academic administrators over
time and then you look up and be like
well of course I need these twenty vice
deans because you know they're all very
busy and they're all very nice people
and then if your costs just creep up
each year because of that because no one
ever forces you to bring your cost down
and then examine whether you need all of
these administrators so as probably you
suggest seem like that there's some
level of corruption in these
institutions I would say that they have
incentives at all cut the same way and
so here's the reality like I ran a
non-profit for seven years and when
you're a non-profit you grow and then
when you grow you say hey like I need to
hire more people and then that person is
there that job is there it always exists
and that's what happens year after year
so your cost creep up and if you're a
university you then pass those costs
along to families and then the families
look up and say well I can't afford this
but then the government says it's okay
I've got your back here's a giant-ass
loan mhmh and so now we're up to one
point six trillion dollars in school
loans
the universities don't have any
incentive to rein in their costs and
families feel like they have no choice
but to pay so what you have to do is you
have to go to the universities and say
look you have to get your costs down and
we're going to put an administrator to
student ratio that's in line with what
you were 15 20 years ago as like a goal
and if you hit that goal then great and
if you don't hit that goal then some
some of the government benefits that you
enjoy are going to get scaled back in
various ways and the universities will
it would hate this but then you look up
and say well I'll figure it out and the
fact is the student experience would not
be adversely affected if you were to get
rid of half a dozen of these like vice
deans that no one knows what they do
it's just right now what's happening in
our universities is a microcosm of
what's happening in a lot of our country
or you have these bureaucracies that
just grow and grow and then choke off
the underlying activity I mean that's
happening in the healthcare industry
it's happening in our schools and these
industries then become like a hidden tax
on all of us so that's that's the move I
would make if you talk to people who are
in the academic track the people who got
PhDs and want to teach or what not none
of them have any tenure-track positions
anymore they're all getting pushed into
these postdoc Purgatory's forever where
they get paid subsistence wages right
get they're not getting rich right right
the educators not getting rich know what
they're doing is they've essentially
constrained the number of educators and
then they've said hey what's that you're
some underpaid PhD we're just gonna
exploit you year after year you're going
to be in this non-tenure-track loop and
then from our perspective if you're in
front of the students it's all good and
then the administrator ranks keep going
seems to me there's a epidemic in this
country of things that are for-profit
that shouldn't be Yale's
health care University all these kinds
of things the tricky thing is that the
universities are like technically
nonprofits but if you're nonprofit you
can still just keep on someone's make no
profit
well like someone's getting money I mean
there's there university presidents and
administrators are getting paid millions
of dollars I mean that is nice but
technically they're nonprofit you know
and and that so but your your statements
100 percent correct it's like there are
a lot of things in this country where
people are making a ton of money like
the prisons like the healthcare
everything else well it's time to wrap
it up no they're getting messages
backstage they're yelling at me they're
saying wrap it up he's a busy man he is
grateful man I'm just grateful to be
here with you all again I wish all my
campaigning was this fun and joy
interesting we just have an intelligent
conversation thank you about a day and
if you're listening to this we have to
solve the problems for you all the
people who are going to inherit this
country I understand if you think
politics is a total disaster mess
because it's depressing and it makes you
think about the scope of the problems
that are coming down on the next
generation
I think it's criminal what we've done to
you all we've left you this disaster I
want to clean it up in the worst way but
I need your help to clean it up I need
to clean it up for my kids for Ethan and
heelas kids for for anyone who's going
to inherit this planet so that we can
look you in the eyes and say we did our
best to leave you something we're proud
of
go to yank 2020 make a donation let's
get yang back on the stage in January I
love seeing you I loved having you back
I'm a big fan I'm yanking all the way as
you can tell one Kay a month
god bless thank you so much for for
coming back yeah thank you thank you all
so much so good luck and what more is
there to say
yang 20:29 is the next debate we're
waiting yeah my % hey it's gonna be an
iOS
[Laughter]
we gotta keep checking in here you know
I love it but yeah I tell you tell you
what that I'll pledge that I will I can
be a running mate I will pledge that we
will do a special agent podcast from the
White House that would be something here
that Super Troopers let's do that you
can you can bring some no vice president
though yeah you know we have to vet you
okay all right guys we'll have a this is
our last episode of the year yeah we are
going to be taking a bout a month break
we'll be back in January for season
three of the h3 podcast guys have a
great Christmas holidays Hanukkah
Kwanzaa parent I don't know anything
about Kwanzaa but they throw that in
there so happy Kwanzaa if that's what
you do Festivus may affect you if
Seinfeld fan oh yeah yeah oh service for
the rest of it you want to wrestle me on
the the trial what did they call the
trial of feets or the great feats of
strength exactly let's have a feats to
strength off-camera of course yeah
you'll take me you're pretty tall yeah
you have good posture too but I have a
low center of gravity so we'll see well
have a good match guys thank you so much
this has been the h3 podcast the most
potent political show of our probably
ever heavier Justin so thank you
everybody have a great holiday families
see you guys in 2020 yank 2020 calm
thanks everybody for watching
you